note that this video is not about a type
of ice cream that kind of looks like a
flag
it's about one of the languages of Italy
one of them what do you mean one of them
well the official language of Italy is
Italian as in standard Italian but all
over the country there are different
forms of speech known as dialetti
meaning dialects one example is
Neapolitan or o napolitana
but are these dialecti dialects of
standard Italian no they didn't develop
from standard Italian but rather
alongside it and most of these dialects
can be grouped together with similar
ones into distinct Regional languages
though most of them are Italo romance
languages just like standard Italian
which itself developed from dialects of
Tuscany I talk a lot about this in my
video languages of Italy Neapolitan is
one of the most widely spoken Regional
languages of Italy and in this video I
think you'll see that it's a distinct
language from Italian even though it's
not officially recognized as a distinct
language let's hear a short clip of
Neapolitan followed by a similar clip in
Italian
foreign
pranzo
Conte and Mercato
the Neapolitan language is spoken in the
metropolitan city of Naples but in its
broadest definition includes the
dialects of other areas of the Campania
region as well as all the areas in
shades of blue on this map
but it's worth pointing out that people
in those other areas often don't refer
to their own dialects as Neapolitan they
associate their speech with their own
local identity and are very aware of the
differences between their speech and
that of Naples even if those differences
are relatively minor if we include all
these closely related Southern varieties
of Italo romance Neapolitan is spoken as
a native language by around 7.5 million
people those people speak standard
Italian as well but sometimes with a
characteristically Neapolitan accent and
the Neapolitan spoken these days is more
influenced by standard Italian than in
previous generations Neapolitan has much
in common with Italian and other romance
languages of course take this sentence
meaning I lived in France for 10 months
word for word I I have lived in France
for 10 months like romance languages in
general Neapolitan has SVO word order
but it's also pro-drop like most romance
languages in other words the subject
pronoun can be dropped
its vocabulary mainly derives from Latin
though its phonology and orthography
might sometimes make cognate words hard
to recognize for speakers of Italian and
other romance languages Neapolitan also
has a similar set of verb tenses to
other romance languages in this sentence
we can see the passato pro simotense
like the present perfect in English
using the auxiliary verb Avi which means
to have plus the past participle form of
the main verb this is a typical past
tense Construction in Italian and most
romance languages but Neapolitan also
has lots of its own features that
distinguish it from Italian and other
romance languages when people refer to
it as a dialect they're giving the
impression that it's an unofficial
variant of Italian reducing its
perceived value or legitimacy our choice
of words can create certain impressions
in people's minds whether it's
intentional or not this is something you
have to be careful of when getting your
information which is why I recommend the
sponsor of today's video ground news
ground news is a global news aggregator
and comparison app which helps make you
aware of the biases in the news you're
reading by showing you how the same
story can be written quite differently
depending on the source this is
especially important these days as the
media becomes more and more polarizing
in order to generate clicks and Views
let's take a look at this story about
Italy and its response to waves of
Asylum Seekers over here we can see that
the stories being covered by 19 News
sources and Below we can see how many of
those sources have a known political
bias to the left right or Center we can
also see a visual representation of the
bias distribution as well as who owns
the new sources
over here if we look at each article we
can see the sources bias as well as its
history of factuality so keeping those
metrics in mind you can read the news
story from different sources and see how
they compare for example one difference
you can see in these two headlines is
that the right-leaning Source says
rejected migrants while the left-leaning
source says rejected refugees the word
Refugee suggests that these people are
fleeing persecution while the word
migrant suggests that they might be
migrating for different reasons when you
see a difference in language like this
that's an opportunity to look at the
details of a story and think about why
different sources describe things
differently reading news from multiple
sources with their own perspectives can
make you a more critical thinker and
help you develop a more nuanced view of
current events in my opinion this is the
antidotes to the extreme polarization
and lack of clarity in today's media use
my link ground.news langfocus for 30 off
on limited access to all of its features
thank you to ground news
and now back to features of the
Neapolitan language
Neapolitan naturally has a large amount
of cognate vocabulary with standard
Italian but numerous little differences
in pronunciation often make it quite
unintelligible to speakers of standard
Italian well those who don't speak a
related dialect that is one example is
that the consonant du is pronounced as a
rhodic in other words an R sound at the
beginning of words and between vowels
for example the word for foot in
standard Italian but a Neapolitan the
word for tooth in standard Italian
but in Neapolitan it's this may show
influence from the auskin language which
was spoken in the area before the
expansion of Latin also notice that the
word has a d rather than a tu sound the
consonant becomes voiced after the nasal
consonant and notice that these
differences are reflected in spelling
another example is that the consonant
cluster ND in Italian corresponds to n n
in Neapolitan for example the word for
World in standard Italian is
while in neapolitanits this may be
another example of Oscar influence
another thing you may have noticed in
the example word so far is that the
unstressed vowel at the end of the word
is reduced to a schwa or even disappears
sometimes this is reflected in spelling
as well with an apostrophe replacing the
final vowel
the word for hand man
hat capital
listen to the vowels in the title of
this classic Neapolitan song
in this recording the final vowel of
this word is reduced so it's Mia I've
heard other people say it with even
heavier reduction like osolumiya with
both final vowels reduced to a schwa
something you'll notice in Neapolitan
spelling and pronunciation is the
doubling of initial consonants in
certain contexts as we saw before the
name of the language is
this is a neuter noun and doubling
occurs after the definite article in
neuter singular nouns Neapolitan has
masculine feminine and neuter gender
unlike Italian which only has masculine
and feminine for the most part o is both
the masculine and neuter singular
definite article the feminine singular
definite article is ah the masculine and
feminine plural is e and there's no
neuter plural definite article doubling
occurs after the neuter singular
definite article or the feminine plural
definite article
there are numerous other words that also
cause doubling in a noun that follows
them for example an adjective when it
comes before a neuter singular or
feminine plural noun
old women some prepositions like ah me
to me and a bunch more you simply have
to memorize which words cause doubling a
similar type of doubling occurs in
standard Italian at least amongst
Central and Southern speakers but it's
not reflected in spelling
another feature of Neapolitan is that
possessive suffixes are used when
referring to family members rather than
the Standalone possessive adjectives
my father even though Neapolitan has the
possessive adjective me in standard
Italian it's
your mother-in-law even though
Neapolitan has the possessive adjective
in standard Italian
my father knows your mother-in-law in
standard Italian this is
even though the verb is used in
Neapolitan the verb sape is used for
people
and that brings us to vocabulary While
most Neapolitan vocabulary is a Tallow
romance like in standard Italian and
developed from Vulgar Latin there are
also words of Greek origin that stem
from the time of a series of Greek
Coastal colonies in southern Italy
founded from the 8th Century BC onwards
even after Naples came under Roman
control in the 3rd Century BC Greek
continued to be spoken alongside Latin
for centuries some words of Greek origin
and Neapolitan include meaning parsley
from Greek Petro celinon
meaning slap from Greek
all plus hand
meaning tastes bad usually for a drink
this comes from Greek kofos even the
name of the city comes from Greek
neapolis which means New City
there are also numerous Spanish and
French words in Neapolitan of course
these are romance words that developed
from Latin but you'll notice that they
resemble Spanish and French words more
than their Italian romance equivalent
for example the word for jewelry is
which comes from the French word Bijou
in Italian it's
the word for yesterday is which comes
from Spanish
Ayer both the Italian word Yeti and the
Spanish word Ayer developed from the
same Latin word so they're similar
anyway but the Neapolitan word came from
Spanish another is the word for below
abash which comes from the Spanish word
avajo in Italian it's Soto
there are also false Friends words of
Latin origin that appear to be the same
but actually have different meanings the
word for head meaning the body part in
standard Italian it's
the Italian word Capo means head in the
sense of a leader
the word for leg in standard Italian
it's Gamba the Italian word kosha means
Thai
now let's look at some basic phrases in
Neapolitan hi
in Italian
is like ciao but the final vowel is
reduced to the point that it's dropped
wait is sometimes reduplicated and you
might hear this which is something like
hey dude while you comes from meaning
girl
good morning
compare this to Italian
good evening
compare that to Italian
good night
see you later
word for word us we see later this is
the equivalent of standard Italian
the first word is the reciprocal pronoun
so this means we'll see each other later
verim and vediamo are equivalent forms
of the cognate verbs
is the equivalent of remember that the
consonant in Neapolitan becomes an R
sound between vowels or at the beginning
of a word
goodbye this is the equivalent of
standard Italian which can be used to
mean be well or take care but isn't the
generally used way to say goodbye in
Italian
notice the somewhat different
conjugation of the verb
also even though the Neapolitan and
Italian verbs are cognates they're used
a little differently in Neapolitan star
is used with the meaning of to be for
temporary conditions as opposed to
essere which means to be for qualities
or permanent conditions similar to the
distinction between Spanish estar and
ser in Italian means to be with both
meanings while study basically means to
stay or remain but can also have the
meaning to be in a certain condition
notice also that in standard Italian the
adverb is used while in Neapolitan the
adjective form is used so the Neapolitan
sentence is literally like be good it
could also be Ben but is used much more
often
what's your name
in Italian
word for word how yourself you call the
Neapolitan sentence and standard Italian
sentences are quite similar but as usual
the Neapolitan pronunciation reduces the
unstressed syllables greatly changing
the sound of the sentence the pronoun
is the second person singular object
pronoun but here it's used as a
reflexive pronoun meaning yourself
my name is Paul
in Italian
word for word myself I call Paul again
the main difference here is vowel
reduction but the words are all
equivalent
where are you from word for word from
where you are in Italian
is the preposition meaning of or from it
takes this form before a consonant and
takes the form D before a vowel they
come from Latin day and I think you can
consider them a single preposition that
gets reduced in two different ways Aro
is the Neapolitan question word meaning
where in Italian it's Dove this word is
one of those cases where the consonant
du becomes an R sound and can be spelled
like this with an R it can also be
written like this with d and is probably
a shortened form of adobe
C is the second person singular present
tense form of which means to be in a
permanent sense so it means you are it's
the equivalent of say in standard
Italian
I'm from Naples
with the word I am from Naples and in
Italian
means I am it's a shortened form of the
first person singular present tense form
of esire song is a cognitive Italian
Sono
I'd like a glass of wine please
with the word I would like a glass of
wine
in Italian this would be Divino
police and the standard Italian word are
conjugations of the cognate verbs
but while the Italian sentence uses the
conditional tense the Neapolitan
sentence uses the imperfect subjunctive
no is the masculine singular indefinite
article which agrees with the masculine
noun that follows the feminine
indefinite article is Na and the article
is an apostrophe before either masculine
or feminine nouns that begin with a
vowel there's no indefinite article
before Newton notes it's the same as the
Italian noun except that the final vowel
is reduced e is the preposition meaning
of and Vina is the equivalent of
standard Italian Vino with a reduced
final vowel
excuse me Where's the restroom
with the word excuse me where is the
restroom in standard Italian this would
be
is the equivalent of standard Italian
which is a plural imperative but a
Neapolitan it's also used for the polite
singular in standard Italian scusi is
the polite singular while skusa is the
informal word
notice also that s is pronounced instead
of in Neapolitan it's pronounced before
consonants other than
is the word for where again is the third
person singular present tense form of
the verb which means to be for
non-permanent conditions but is also
used for locations notice again that in
standard Italian the verb essere is used
instead because would mean to stay or
remain
means the restroom notice that the
initial k sound in this word becomes
voiced between vowels you'll hear this
quite a lot in Neapolitan
I understand
literally I have understood in standard
Italian
and oh are both the first person
singular present forms of ADI or meaning
to have note that Ave is only used as an
auxiliary verb while a different word is
used for possession in standard Italian
the verb is used for both Italian also
has the verb meaning to hold or to keep
you've probably noticed that the
Neapolitan infinitive doesn't have the
final re that we see in the Italian
infinitive here's another example I like
to watch movies
compare that to Italian film
one more thing to note here is that
again we see that the consonant K
becomes voiced G between vowels and can
be spelled with a G instead of a c
I'm sure you can see that Neapolitan is
quite similar to other romance languages
including standard Italian but it also
has numerous differences from standard
Italian including differences in its
phonology that make it quite a challenge
for speakers of standard Italian to
understand unless they also speak a
related Southern dialect that is reading
is probably much easier but that's the
case for romance languages in general
isn't it so while Neapolitan and
standard Italian are very closely
related it seems very reasonable to me
to consider Neapolitan a distinct
Regional language of Italy if you're a
speaker of standard Italian who doesn't
speak Neapolitan how well are you able
to understand it and if you're a speaker
of Neapolitan to what extent do you use
it and to what extent do you use
standard Italian
and now it's time to give a shout out to
the langfocus patreon supporters who
make videos like this possible the
people whose names appear right here on
the screen are the top tier patreon
supporters so let's give them an extra
special thanks if you liked this video
be sure to check out my video on the
languages of Italy and my video on
Italian I'm sure you'll find them as
fascinating as this video or even more
so